for better or worse I get the McDreamy
thing a lot move over McDreamy I've
never seen the man in action in fact
I've never seen a full Grey's Anatomy
episode but you asked for it so you got
it a month ago you were in med school
being taught by doctors today you aren't
the doctors first of all I've never
heard a speech given that dramatically
on an interns first day nobody really
talks like that it's much more practical
five of you will crack under the
pressure of two of you of the athlete
this is your starting line this is your
arena
this sounds like Hunger Games more than
it does Grey's Anatomy no I'm not
getting it it's just that uh you know
you were very unforgettable O'Malley
yang great Steven we do get ready
together in the mornings there are
locker rooms like this it's funny to say
but because doctors spend a lot of time
in books while in medical school they're
not the greatest at interacting with
others or maybe even showing interest in
the opposite sex so I've seen situations
like this happen a lot where someone's
trying to make conversation but they're
not great at it so it comes off very
awkward it's funny but this is very
accurate you're interns grunts nobodies
bottom of the surgical food chain
residents don't work 48-hour calls
anymore they're capped at 80 hours per
week maybe they go a little bit over
that sometimes but 48 hours is just
non-existent and this started because of
the Libby Zion law which is sadly the
name of a young girl who died because
residents who were so overworked they
miss catching a diagnosis and she
ultimately died run labs write orders
work every second
till you drop and don't complain on-call
rooms
wait the on-call rooms look exactly like
this they're very plain they're very
basic the hospital doesn't budget or
allocate any money towards them you have
to change your own sheets the mattresses
are basically plastic uncomfortable so
this is very accurate dr. Bailey shotgun
that means every test in the book CT CBC
chem seven tox screen
I love how simply the attending came in
and made that decision he basically saw
maybe the chart maybe a brief
explanation of what happened why the
patient came in and he already has a
shotgun approach to this this is not how
medicine works that's ineffective you
need to have a presumed diagnosis in
place so that the labs and tests you
order actually confirm a diagnosis you
can't just throw stuff against the wall
shotgun against the wall whatever he
said and hope something sticks the only
time that is appropriate is if you have
no idea why a young otherwise healthy
patient with an unknown history comes in
with some sort of weird presentation
then you can start ordering a broad
range of tests but they knew she had a
seizure history so why are they doing a
CT scan I need more info more info
please plus your cell this is where
these medical dramas get me they make it
seem like the doctors do everything from
A to Z they diagnose the patient they
run the tests on the patient they draw
the blood they transport the patient we
have nurses we have a maze we have
transport staff with PT therapists we
have respiratory therapists understand
that they're trying to build the
character so they're trying to show as
much of them as possible I'm just gonna
insert my fingers into your rectum
why fingers just one finger but you
missed a lot when you first started out
no one was ever that mean people wanted
you to learn they wanted you to get
better if you go into every procedure or
every moment within residency with the
concept that you want to learn and you
want to do better people respect that so
I don't I don't necessarily get this
hatred that these poor interns are
getting our cafeterias are bare-bones
with usually not the greatest food
available in fact this is what surprises
me most about hospitals we try and tell
people to eat healthy and stay healthy
but the only options to eat our pizza
burgers chicken fingers the most
unhealthy foods possible it's crazy to
me you know I'm not the doctor I'm a
doctor but I'm not Katie's doctor so
I'll go get him for you very common
situation to find yourself in especially
at on nights when you're covering for
the entire Hospital and some medical
emergency happens the family wants
answers they have a lot of very
important questions that they need
answered but you don't know the patient
you need to put a lot of information
together rather quickly and create a
thought process that the family can
follow along with you so they know
what's going on you don't have to give a
direct answer a lot of residents young
residents especially think that they
don't have the exact right truthful
answer that they're bad that's not true
even seasoned attendings know that
there's times to say we don't know yet
what's going on dr. Shepherd he's over
there
why did I know mr. McDreamy guys gonna
pop in to see oh wait did they not know
each other dr. Shepherd this isn't
appropriate that ever occurred to you I
agree with her in a position of power
you should not be involved into these
types of situations they don't happen
that often as much as we like to believe
that there's so much love and drama
going on in hospitals doesn't happen as
much as you think it does but I have a
little she may come back for more with
the wonderful dr. Shepherd
[Applause]
usually we wear eye protection because
if blood squirts out into your eye
that's pretty dangerous so at least have
goggles or the face shield that comes
attached to the mask now is rather quick
I guess that's for TV's sake in a
reality there's a lot of conversation
that occurs between the attending and
the intern especially with identifying
landmarks they'll often ask you really
hard questions and we call that pimping
and they'll ask you questions that are
unrelated to the case so you've prepared
for this case but they'll ask you
something else it's a very common okay
give them a clap bp's dropping he's
choking come on George let's go who
talks like that bullying falls out of
your bag double-o seven is a state of
mind this is a girl finished first in
her class at Stanford we lived with the
vending machines I used to eat Snickers
galore when I forgot to bring my healthy
alternatives from home mr. Jones his
junky veins and he really needs
antibiotics I should start a central
line to start one you know know how I
couldn't lay I'm very passionate about
this starting a central line just
because you couldn't get a vein with a
needle prick is crazy it's crazy you're
putting the patient at risk dr. Bailey I
mean father you've no doubt it's mr.
Joey says he's dying No then stop
talking to me she should have gone to a
nurse because nurses have way more
experience than even doctors in getting
a blood draw it's time you wake me so
close to did this and that patient
doesn't look alive for some reason oh no
he blinked okay he's alive are you sure
that's the right diagnosis I don't know
I'm only an intern here's an idea why
don't you go spend four years in med
school in the lemmino office um right
diagnosis oh that's what we call a
cowboy
intern basically a cowboy intern is
someone who is so confident in their
diagnosis that they start their
treatment they don't explore any other
options they don't have a good
differential meaning other options of
why
the illness could be nurses keep the
hospital running without them we would
not be able to do our jobs a lot of
times they'll catch our mistakes they'll
be able to identify things we could be
doing better this is the most drama I've
ever seen happen in the first 24 hours
of being an intern the rest pans not
working phenobarbital loaded with
phenobarbital okay when you say loader
with phenobarbital that's not an order
you need to give the dosage the nurse
needs to say back to you to make sure
that you heard the same thing that you
said otherwise if the nurse misheard you
and you didn't even give the instruction
of how much to give they can give Eddie
dose so that could be lethal to a
patient so that's not real
okay so hard stopping that's the code
blue I've talked about this before now
the patient is dead if the heart has
stopped the patient is technically dead
and you have to work to revive them to
get their heart started back up again as
the resident in charge you have to
instantly give roles to everybody you do
chest compressions you do this you give
the medications you monitor the rhythm
strip the most important role being
chest compressions you have to do chest
compressions you cannot stop doing chest
compressions
so if you have one person that's giving
bad chest compressions because they're
tired you instantly have to swap them
out because chest compressions is what
extends and saves lives so right now
them not doing chest compressions is
awful the first thing you do is chest
compressions whoa I hope she's not gonna
shock the patient oh my god please tell
me she's not gonna lie no no what are
you doing grey's Anatomy's no nothing no
oh she's in v-fib then why is this
telling she's flatlining
[Music]
I've never thrown up in a hospital I've
never seen a doctor throw up in the
hospital unless they were sick yeah when
things go wrong you get nauseous that's
part of life I mean that there's
difficult moments that happen there's
times where you're gonna be humbled I
mean every day I walked into the
hospital as a resident I was humbled
there's a reason why we call it
practicing medicine because we're all
practicing we're all learning we're all
adapted we're all trying to get better
and the human body's a crazy crazy thing
that we still don't have perfect
knowledge of so I feel for her a little
bit you know just a little bit a little
dramatic what I feel for her yes our man
has a seizure disorder now you're saying
it isn't I'm saying that I don't know oh
my man McDreamy saying my line real
doctors are comfortable saying I don't
know because in reality there's a lot we
don't know
and when cases get very complex like
this young girl who's otherwise healthy
is having seizures and then her heart
stopping it's a very unusual case very
very unusual
I want someone else a doctor who knows
what they're doing you get me someone
else someone better than you these types
of conversations do happen this is real
life people get very very upset it takes
a lot of patience to deal with these
issues I've seen doctors get mad and
snap what I do is if I feel like I'm
getting angry as well I step away from
the situation let both parties cool down
and then come back and explain calmly
what we're working on because if you
just say we don't know with no follow-up
it seems like you're not doing anything
but if you say we don't know but here's
what we think it might be and here's
what we're working towards that's a much
better answer he'll be fine right Tony's
gonna sail through
you have nothing to worry about promise
patients need reassurance you need to
give honest reassurance without over
promising them results what are you
doing I'm suturing a banana with the
vain hope that a wakes up my brain okay
suturing bananas suturing pigs feet is
something very common that med students
and interns do so that's it is true
she's gonna die if I don't make a
diagnosis which is where you can I can't
do it alone
I need your extra minds extra eyes this
is very dramatic every day we have
meetings known as rounds where we sit
around a table like this we present a
complicated patient we give the history
we give the physical we give the test
results and we all brainstorm ideas of
what it could be how we would approach
the case and it's very good practice
even if we already know the outcome but
sometimes we don't know the outcome and
we are brainstorming like you said here
but it's not this dramatic can't comment
they face or react me anyway
we had sex
[Music]
bum-bum-bum
Katie competes and beauty pageants I
know that but we have to save her life
anyway okay she has no headaches no neck
pain pursuit is clean there's no medical
proof of an aneurysm first of all this
is known as a HIPAA violation
they're basically talking about a
patient's case using her name in front
of other people who are not involved in
her case and that is strictly against
the law they could get sued for millions
of dollars and rightfully so because you
shouldn't be discussing patient
information elevators in fact in most
hospitals you'll see a sign in the
elevator that says please don't discuss
patient information wow that was quick
this heart has too much damage to give
them off bypass I have to let him go
what happens rarely but it does happen
where's part of the game when he gave
that promise to the family saying that
he's definitely gonna make it
Tony's heart had a lot of damage thank
you don't do this type of conversation
in an open setting like this you invite
the family and into a counseling room
you explain what happened but you don't
do it out in the open like this because
this is just gonna end badly you should
want to find it we had sex get the way
of you taking your shot should have had
sex period dr. Shepherd name the common
causes of post-op fever the five W's
brah can anybody name the common causes
of post-op fever I don't like this is
you G wind water wound walking wander
drugs yes how would you diagnose I hope
she says CT Cyril CT and now thank you
scanners provide o 2dos with heparin and
consult for an IVC filter oh she just
gave all of the options that you have in
testing somebody for a pulmonary
embolism as well as treatments that you
may give to someone with a pulmonary
embolus I'd know you anywhere
you got the spitting image of your
mother welcome to the game welcome to
the game
I've never heard a doctor speak like
that welcome to the game
you never want to sleep on a stretcher
as a resident because it's bad luck it
basically says that you couldn't wind up
on a stretcher you have the on-call
rooms you have couches you could knock
out on so sleeping on a stretcher it's
just bad form I should go do this you
should the bromance is real I'll see you
around
thud McDreamy would have a little more
muscle on him be kind of looking a
little frail there whoa there you have
it my first Grey's Anatomy episode is in
the books and you were here to
experience it with me all in all I'm
pleasantly surprised with this Grey's
Anatomy episode because I assume there's
gonna be just way more loving and sex
and that's what the whole show is gonna
be about and in reality did take a deep
dive into how a resident feels and what
their work is like so I thought that was
pretty good and it surprised me Medical
accuracy obviously weak but I don't
think most people watch Grey's Anatomy
because they want to become doctors and
they want to learn about the human body
I think it's an entertainment show first
and foremost and I think it does a great
job at that I told you if you got my
real doctor verse TV doctor video to ten
thousand likes I would watch an episode
of Grey's Anatomy and I did as promised
so now if you want me to watch another
episode of Grey's Anatomy one of your
favorites or the good doctor or house
leave it down below in the comments get
this video now to 15,000 likes which I
know you're totally capable of because
the last video you got to like 19,000
likes please subscribe to the channel
because the more subscribers we have the
more content and better content I can
constantly create as always stay happy
and healthy
[Music]